so Gumi you're which I agree with you're
telling us to have hard to break into
passwords but then the obvious question
is how does a normal human being manage
all of these passwords that don't have
regular words in them they can't reuse
the same password over and over how do
we how do we manage all of this yes
great question it is really hard to keep
up with all of the different services I
don't know about you but
but over 100 services and the only
reason I know that is actually because I
I've used a password manager and seeing
the list actually surprised me and
password managers are great because they
can automatically save the passwords for
you and they're super convenient because
once you go back to a website not only
do they check that it's not um like a
phishing website or somebody pretending
to be the legitimate website but they'll
also conveniently fill in your password
for you and you just click a button and
so it's super quick especially if you're
on mobile it's been a lifesaver
and password one thing that I've always
worried about password managers is
sometimes I'm logging in from my laptop
sometimes from my phone sometimes from
my wife's laptop well the password
managers work across multiple devices
yeah different password managers
definitely have different capabilities
but at least on Google when you're
signed into your Google account on the
various devices then yes we can pull
together all of the information from
that password manager and display it on
the different devices that you're using
and how do you compare a password
manager which can kind of store all of
these things locally and and and be able
to you know fill in when you need it and
keep track of it to be able to use a
service you know you have obviously
Google has it you have apple you have
other other folks who have you know once
you sign into that account that allows
you to sign into other accounts do you
recommend both how do you compare those
those two things
um I think it's up to the user's choice
and so um sometimes users are going to
be limited because of what the website
developer has done so for example not
all websites offer the sign in with
Google with Apple sign in with Facebook
Etc
um but all websites do have passwords
and so at a minimum you can always you
know have your own username and password
for that service and then store it in
the password manager alternatively if
you don't want to create a bunch of new
accounts all over the internet you could
definitely lose your Google account for
instance and sign in into various
services using your Google account I
personally like that option because it
actually reduces the number of different
accounts I have to worry about and of
course Google is backed by you know the
strongest security among the strongest
in the industry so it's something that I
feel good about thanks for that gooey